So let's write some Python code to solve this particular example.
So here's a translation of that problem and the solution into Python.
So first I have a list of the connections in that graph
we were just looking at--nodes A through H.
And for each of these pairs, I go through and make a link in a Graph G.
Then I write a piece of code to list the component sizes
for that Graph G, and here's what the output looks like.
Then we'll go back and look at what the algorithm is.
It goes through and identifies that there's two components.
One we'll just name little A
because it contains node little A; it has four nodes in it.
Then there's a separate component that's not connected to the first one
that contains B, and that also has four nodes.
In fact, looking back at the graph here, that's exactly what we see.
There's the purple nodes, which include node A,
and then there's these blue-green nodes
four of which are visible here that include B.
So it finds the right stuff. How does it go about doing this?
Well, it essentially uses the same algorithm that I did
when I was doing it by hand, but of course it does it in code.
The main routine that we call is called mark component.
So that's kind of like what I was doing when I was turning nodes purple,
and it works like this: we give it the graph that we're working on,
the current node that we're marking,
and data structure that keeps track of which things have been marked so far.
Call this routine on this node,
That's a new node; we haven't seen it before, and so we mark it.
So that means we've visited that node, and we say
that in this particular call to the routine
so far we've marked exactly one node.
Then we look at all the neighbors of that node.
For each of them, we say
if that neighbor of the node that we're looking at
hasn't been marked so far,
then what we're going to do is recursively
call mark a component on that neighbor.
It's going to go and get everywhere that it can get to
that it hasn't already gotten to,
mark them all, and return.
What it returns is the number of nodes that it marked
as part of this process.
However many nodes it marked,
we're going to add that to the total number marked.
So we marked our current node, then we visited a neighbor
and marked all the nodes connected to that neighbor,
then we come back and repeat this loop
for all the different neighbors of the node where we started.
When that's exhausted, it means we've now reached out
and touched all the nodes that are touchable
from node node.
And so we return the total that were actually marked as part of this process
and then it's done.
So that's the main routine that does all the hard work..
There's also a routine on the outside
that takes a graph
and starts off saying nothing's been marked so far.
We just have an empty data structure.
Then what we're going to do is loop through all the nodes in the graph
because we don't know which ones are going to be the beginnings
of a new component or not.
For each one that we visit, we say if that node hasn't been marked
in some previous iteration, then we've got a new component.
This node that we're just visiting is a part of that component.
So we say, "Hey, we've got a component containing node node."
Then what we do is we recursively go
and mark all the things connected to that node,
count up how many things got marked in that way, and then we return.
So what we know is there was a component, it contained node node,
and it has a certain count to it.
When it's done that, it moves on to the next node.
A bunch of these have probably already been marked,
so they just get skipped really quickly,
but eventually it maybe reaches a node that hasn't been marked
because it wasn't connected to anything so far.
Prints that one out and continues.
So this really is very explicitly what we were doing by hand,
just one piece at a time.